take a look at these two guns one is an
ar-15 style rifle that's been altered
with something called a juggernaut
tactical hell fighter kit the other is a
classic colt ar-15 the two guns look
kind of different but they have a lot of
the same features and a lot of
similarities in how they shoot the
biggest difference you actually can't
see one has been illegal in California
for more than 30 years which is why we
had to use a photo the other you can buy
at a local gun store over the past few
decades lawmakers in California have
repeatedly tried to ban what they define
as assault weapons and each time gun
manufacturers responded by making small
changes so they could continue selling
that style of gun in the state one of
these guns an ar-15 style rifle was used
in April in a shooting at a synagogue
near San Diego despite California's bans
the gun the shooter was using was
perfectly legal in the state according
to law enforcement officials familiar
with the investigation to understand how
this happened you have to look at how
guns in the state have evolved first
here's the colt ar-15 again this is
approximately what ar-15s looked like
back before the state's first ban in
1989 and what they still look like in
states that haven't passed bans it has a
pistol grip and a flash suppressor
features the California lawmakers have
since said make the weapons particularly
dangerous this type of gun was banned in
1989 after a gunman entered a school in
Stockton California and opened fire he
killed five and injured 32 others using
an ak-47 after that the state passed the
Roberti reus assault weapons Control Act
which bans certain guns by name in
response gun makers started developing
similar guns with different names that
meant that guns like the colt ar-15 were
changed slightly and resold with names
like the Colts Porter
then in 1999 lawmakers amended the law
to ban weapons with specific parts such
as semi-automatic rifles with detachable
magazines pistol grips thumbhole stocks
folding stocks grenade launcher flash
suppressors and forward pistol grips but
there was a way around this guns with
fixed magazines could keep these
features could be a bullet so gun makers
modified guns so the magazines could be
changed with a single bullet which met
the state's definition of a tool this
allowed them to keep the band features
and still sell guns with magazines that
could be changed without much trouble
this became known as the bullet button
loophole this bullet button modification
was legal in California for around a
decade then in 2015 two shooters stormed
a holiday gathering in San Bernardino
California and killed 14 people they
were carrying ar-15 style rifles with
bullet buttons they had bought in
California and then illegally altered
after the shooting lawmakers tried to
pass new legislation this time they
focused on closing the bullet button
loophole this incident caught the
attention of a state lawmaker by the
name of Steve Glazer and so he does
something to ban these bullets and what
he does is changes the definition of a
fixed magazine to one that cannot be
removed without the distance
three of the firearm the law passed
which meant bullet button guns were
banned and yet again modifications were
made so that more AR style features
could be kept
remember the AR style rifle with the
juggernaut tactical hell fighter from
the beginning
the juggernaut tactical hell fighter is
a kit that alters an assault-style rifle
so that users can change the magazine by
cracking open the action just a hair
like this gun dealers say this legally
counts as disassembly of the firearm
action so gun makers started here and
decades later after multiple assault
weapon bans they ended here California
compliant ar-15 as they're called she's
just the same as a normal and here
fifteen the bullets going just as fast
Smith & Wesson Ruger cult and juggernaut
did not respond to a request for comment
a spokesperson from the National
Shooting Sports Foundation a trade group
for gun manufacturers said of the state
laws quote they're basing the bans
strictly on cosmetic features that have
no bearing on the operation or the
function of the firearm a spokesperson
for the California state attorney
general declined to comment on the
modified weapons